I want you to recall back to when we did
tree to making relationships and we said
look so the cosine they're related their
compliments in fact you can see the
whole shifting over 90 degrees business
on the graph right and we also said that
tan X is related to both of these guys
as well what's the relationship between
to that in terms of 10x and these two
other rescues what was the relationship
get remember something over something
1080i no side over cars very good I my
music color so I'm going to try and be
consistent I've got sign on the top and
I've got cause on the bottom and I just
realized that my pink and red with very
similar to you so I might try something
else let's try this okay so does that
look a little bout you see the
difference more clearly step it up yeah
okay so you've got in black now here's
what we going to do we are going to
graph this guy that's why you have graph
paper in front of you okay now we could
graph this just the same way we graphed
sign I could give you also values
chuckling your calculators where you
come out the front and we can plot
points okay in a work we can get a graph
okay however there's a better way two
genders here's how I would like and
think um plotting points to graph
something I'm is a little bit like
coming to a locked door come in to a
locked on your like I tried you open
this door how shall I do it okay
plotting points and just you know
machining up points requiring 30 people
to do it it's kind of the mathematical
climate of taking a sledgehammer and
knocking down the door by brute force
okay it takes a lot of time takes a lot
of pledging numbers but it works okay a
sledgehammer if you're strong enough
it'll open the door okay but doesn't
require much finesse or elegant it's not
a very clever solution okay it just
happens to work because you're
overwhelmed at with you know time and
effort okay a better way to do this this
is why we have graph paper
is to think about how sine and cosine
relate and come together to make 10 okay
this is kind of like mathematical cumin
rather than knocking the door down the
sledgehammer it's kind of like learning
to pick locks okay I don't know if any
of you know how to pick locks I've tried
to learn I can pick pick a very very
very very basic like okay basically a
lot that wouldn't be any good for
actually might be something but I can
still pick it okay that took me weeks to
learn that learning to pick locks is
hard especially if you're uncor de nerd
like I am but it's a far more thoughtful
and clever way of doing it and also
doesn't require you to be strong enough
to use a sledgehammer like I am to open
a door okay so this is going to be a bit
harder than just trucking values into
your calculator okay but it's going to
require more for and it's going to get
you a better understanding what's going
on so let's have a go at this you can
see the computers provide us which are
with a whole bunch of um values for
those angles along the x-axis can you
see that okay but they're not kind of
the there in increments of 50 you see
that I've got 50 100 150 etc okay which
for trigonometric graphs is not actually
that useful okay so for instance we're
going to mark some of these extra angles
in that are important to us together
let's have a look here can you see that
first time a pink graph that's our
that's cause can you see the first time
that caused intersects with the x-axis
right what value is that just read it
off it's 90 degrees right so i can put
me in a 90 yeah i'm going to skip the
degrees because i've just trying to like
these as small as I can that's the first
time that caused hits the x-axis you can
also see side hit the x axis over here
but it hits again right in the middle
what's that that's 180s and you can read
off the lines right I cosine goes down
and then it comes back up it hits the
x-axis the gear right and you can see
it's 12 squares after 250 so that makes
it soo 70 very good okay and then right
at the very end you can see I finish
both of my graphs in fact they finish at
360 now remember
back to last week the grass stir really
finish okay they don't really stop like
that they keep on going forever but I
just draw these sections for you so you
can see the pattern and the patterns
that you get here remember the grass
repeat we haven't named that started p
remember we grass repeated you descend
you're over and over and over again
regular frequency we call that periodic
right there's a period to it ok so the
period of both of these ranches 360
degrees if i were to keep on going this
pit grasp right to do another one of
these i would just keep on going over
here and will be the same shape just
copied again ok and of course it goes in
this direction as well to the left now
10 x is the green graph / the pink wrap
the green graph / the pink brown ok so
even though i'm not going to use a
calculator once for this entire exercise
okay i can still know there are lots of
Point C where I know what's going on for
instance right now we just labeled a few
extra values on that x axis right here 0
180 360 we call those the intercepts of
the sine curve ok there where it
intercepts with the x axis now I'm doing
great / peak see that green / peek at
this point down here the green is 0 you
see that now if you could zero on the
numerator of your fraction I don't care
what the denominator is right you can
have 0 / 10 / hundreds your rockmelon
you're still going to get 0 okay so
therefore 10 is 0 / something the tan
graph will be 0 at that point you see
that tan has to be 0 over there it just
so happens that it's going to be 0 / 1
which is 0 it doesn't matter once over
it's 0 I had the same kind of thing
happening over here in the middle you
see that the greed is 0 and the pic is
what's that down the bottom it's going
to be minus 1 right negative 10 / I
don't care what is equal to also be 0 so
you can see these crosses that I'm
putting I'm trying to plot the part
of the tan curve okay this is where the
tankards could go through I've done
those two intercepts 0 180 there's one
more point where I know the tag curve
will be zero where is it over there at
360 see that it's going to be 0 / 1 all
over again because I've gone all the way
back to the start so for next there now
that's all right but that's hardly
enough to graph the whole thing right
you guys put like 30 points onto the
board before we drew just a small
section of sign so let's have a look
there are some other interesting points
here can you see right here right that's
where green MP got equal to each other
sine and cosine have the same value now
there are two ways you can know what
this is you can just look you've got a
graph you've got a scale there you can
see what that angle is right look it's
halfway between 40 and 50 it's 45 degree
it's isn't it but you knew that already
didn't you because remember sine 45
right because cosine is the compliment
right what's the cultivator 45 also 45
right so sine 45 and cost 45 of both
equal they're both as we just saw when
they're both 102 okay if you think back
a few more lessons that was roughly 0.7
have a look at your graph have a look at
your graph do you see where it lives
there's one right on the access right
one point nine point eight point seven
it's pretty much bang on okay so tell me
being the tan inside over cosine it's a
green of a pink when sine and cosine of
the same what's sine divided by cosine
it's one right whatever values these are
if they're the same when you divide them
lead over sorry green / peak something
over itself is just one ok so at 45
degrees the tankard right above you will
be equal to 1 do you see that you see
where I got one from what is
they're on the left hand side right so a
value green / peak which is the same is
one okay this is good this is good I can
see some other points that are similar
to this right for example if you ever
ruler there if you don't you can for our
one if you have a ruler I want you to
have a look over to see how that was 45
degrees forty-five degrees in there 45
degrees forty-five was exactly halfway
between door and 19 juicy not exactly
half way and in fact if I cover up the
rest of this you can see look it's kind
of well it's not kind of it's exactly
symmetric or so that's why it's banger
the middle but if I just cover up a
different part of the graph see this
part here this is between 90 and 180 can
you see you have another kind of
symmetry right this one starts at on the
left-hand side of running out of here
you just type 1 you come down to 0
whereas the pit graph starts at zero
goes down to negative 1 so they're kind
of doing opposite things so therefore if
you're halfway between here and you get
the same value if I go halfway between
90 and 180 what is that what's halfway
between 90 and 180 you can literally
measure it out what's that value
remember it's 45 degrees overheating so
if I were 45 or you're 45 more it should
be 135 right under the bed all right
roulade ready what you'd have a look I
want you to measure how high the green
graph is and then measure how low the
pink graft is you have a look
online I look like I'm getting something
like 21 millimeters up to the green
graph 21 millimeters up to the greek and
if i move my ruler down it looks to me
like I go 21 millimeters down to the
pink do you see that 21 millimeters in
other words it's the same distance it's
just that once positive and one negative
do you understand so if i take some
number well i don't know what the number
is but it doesn't matter if i take some
number and i divide it by the same
number but negative okay regardless of
what the number is you're always going
to get the same answer namely negative 1
okay remember how over here on 45
degrees we got positive 1 well down here
I got you get where's negative i'm going
to be there there is you see I've read
negative 1 off the left-hand side of the
graph okay so got some values happening
here okay let's keep on going from left
to right look see how at 45 degrees the
two graphs were exactly the same there's
another point where that happens you see
where that happens it's here halfway
between 180 and 270 are you starting to
get a pattern yeah right what is the
actual angle halfway between 180 and 270
it's get me 225 is it I keep going
forward in 45 degree troublesome 225 and
look sine and cosine greeted peak there
exactly equal to each other what did we
conclude when you take two numbers that
are the same and you divide them you
just get one right even if they're both
negative well the negatives cancel each
other right so 225 I should be at one
okay how are we going so far we've
traced out a whole bunch of points so
far but it's still not enough for me to
connect things ok so I'm going to stop
for a second and come back to earlier on
here in the ground anyone in the back